Speaker 1: We've talked now for a while about
how if the American Right is really harping
on the left is doing this, we should really
be considering whether it is they themselves
that are doing it.
This is called projection.
This is accusing others of doing that, which
you are doing.
And when it comes to free speech and cancel
culture, the right has been making a living
in some cases, literally making a living when
it comes to some of these right wing media
outlets by saying the left wants to cancel
anybody they don't agree with and the left
wants to take away your free speech.
We have a fascinating but disturbing new report
about the book ban, effort and book ban.
Efforts have hit their highest level in at
least 20 years, and it is not the left that
is doing it.
It is the right that is trying to do it.
So we are going to look at this report from
the American Library Association.
It was released earlier this week.
The report found over 700 challenges to library,
school and university materials in 2021.
This is the most since at least 2000.
The ALA has only been tracking such efforts
since the year 2000, so we can say it's been
at least 20 years, but maybe more.
Axios goes on to say book bands have risen
substantially over the past year as conservative
groups have challenged public school libraries
and successfully purged books from those libraries,
generally about LGBTQ issues, which they like
to frame as, you know, inappropriate gender
and sexuality indoctrination and books about
people of color, which they often like to
frame as teaching white people to feel bad
or critical race theory, or whatever the case
may be.
Now there's a bunch of different important
elements to this that we need to talk about.
First is again, I'm going to say this a bunch
of times.
This is right wingers.
This is right wingers doing this.
They say they are for free speech, but they
want to ban or challenge books.
They say they are against canceling, but they
want to cancel authors of books or cancel
a teacher's right or ability to say, Here's
the material I want to teach with, and here's
how I'm going to teach with it.
They are the ones who are the experts in education,
but it is random people who say, No, no, no,
no, you shouldn't be allowed to do that.
Now that is the projection and hypocrisy piece.
Oftentimes, you know, the people most loudly
talking about free speech are the ones trying
to limit it.
When is it OK to ban books?
Is it ever OK to ban books in this?
There is an important and serious conversation
to have.
In other words.
Are we saying block certain books from being
published?
Basically never.
There is essentially never.
We might be able to come up with a couple
of examples of when we are saying it should
be against the law for a publisher to even
publish certain books.
Are we saying don't have certain books in
certain libraries?
OK, well, so let's now imagine.
Should there be pornography in an elementary
school library up?
No.
Should there be books that are instruction
manuals on how to make bombs in elementary
school libraries?
Probably not.
But here we're already talking about age restrictions.
That's very different than a ban.
And then there's the question of, well, what
about as part of class curriculum?
Should eight year olds have certain materials
as part of their class curriculum?
And they're my idea is similar to my view
on responsible platforming.
Sometimes I'll interview a lunatic extremist.
We used to interview the people from that
Westboro Baptist Church, and we would get
emails sometimes from people saying, you shouldn't
have these people on because your platforming
them.
And my response was responsible.
Platforming means I've determined the views
are worth exposing.
And I feel equipped to make it clear that
the views are disgusting.
And that was the difference between some of
the interviews I would do and some of the
ones that you would see elsewhere.
Similarly, I would apply the same kind of
test when it comes to school curriculum.
I understand saying, you know, we don't want
teachers teaching Hitler's Mein Kampf unless
they are equipped to teach it correctly and
to teach it in a way that makes it abundantly
clear that these are the disgusting views
of a xenophobic, authoritarian maniac who
had six million Jews killed.
It starts to get more complicated.
There's not one answer.
But the point here is.
We are not saying ban the book.
We are not saying burn the book.
And I remember in my high school history of
film class, there were discussions about what
movies is it OK for 14 year olds to watch?
What level of gratuitous violence and sexuality
is OK for the classroom doesn't mean, you
know, throw away.
What would at the time were DVDs doesn't mean
don't allow parents to weigh.
But there were questions like what is appropriate
for 14 year olds to watch in school?
It's a fair question.
Is it too sexually explicit?
And then we get to the hypocritical aspect
of the book bands that they demand, and that
can't be ignored because they'll say, Oh,
this is too sexually explicit, but they're
OK with the sexuality that's in the Bible,
which is extreme and significant.
They say this is too violent, but they're
OK with all of the violence in the Bible.
They make exceptions there, so the hypocrisy
is a major component.
There is a real conversation to be had here,
and in almost all cases, we shouldn't be banning
books, but we can't even have that conversation
with the right because they just want them
axed.
They want to decide what teachers are allowed
to do.
They want to decide what librarians are allowed
to have in the library, and it's a bad faith
conversation from the ground up.
Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at Packman and
let me know what you think